foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
driver all I ever wanted to do is be a
racer I'm doing it
the 10 of you are the best
Gran Turismo players in the world now is
your chance to race real cars it's not
gonna work the guys who race are Elite
athletes your kids are scrawny little
gamer kids that's where you come in
so you think you can do the impossible
I'm here to prove that you can't you get
tired
you puked on my lawn
I know what I'm doing not afraid I've
raced this track a thousand times in the
game let me drive it my way
that was actually pretty great
we have a newcomer this year his
presence is shaking the foundation of
the sport this is the major leagues the
other driver your pit crew are going to
hate you it's much easier with a
joystick isn't it
I can't see anything
I'm not sure if I can do this most
people can't
I got a feeling you're not most people
if I lose I lose more than just a Race
So I'm not gonna quit you've got to
prove to everyone
[Music]
embraced it what like a thousand times
now you just gotta do it in real life
Gran Turismo based on a true story